here at home israelis and supporters
gathered on the strip
to call for an end as well that's where
we find sasha loftis tonight with more
on this conflict
and the people coming out sasha
brian those we spoke with today say this
group out here in las vegas is a real
sign of our local support
for peace in the middle east now while
this particular group
was standing behind israel they say they
just
really want to see peace altogether
flying flags honking horns and heartfelt
messages
we want to just show our unity show our
voice show our support
are all signs of community support as a
conflict continues in the middle east
we really just want to show the world
their support out there for israel
hundreds gathered in las vegas wednesday
to band together as violence flares
between israeli and palestinian forces
my mom my sisters my nephews my cousins
are in shelters and as an
israeli-american who live here in the
states
i fear for their lives but i also fear
for our life here
as jews in america those here are
standing in solidarity with israel
but hundreds have died on both sides as
the decades-long conflict
reignited a few weeks ago
they hope their presence at home will
shed real light on the issue at hand
it's terrible that we can not really do
anything
except show our support to our country
show our love
and encourage peace for those they love
who are suffering so many miles away
we're strong and we're going to be ok
there were about two to 300 people who
participated in today's convoy
they all met up at sunset park around 4
30 this afternoon
then drove up and down the las vegas
strip here for about three hours from
around
6 to 9 p.m with metro police following
closely behind
to make sure that demonstration remained
peaceful reporting live tonight sasha
loftis
8 news now